CBS News confirms a Federal grand jury
has indicted former president Trump on
charges of mishandling classified
documents at his Mar-A-Lago estate in
Florida this is a hugely significant
development it's the first time in
American history that a former president
has been indicted on federal charges
three sources familiar with the case say
the seven count indictment involves the
retention of National Defense
information conspiracy and obstruction
Trump made the announcement on his
social media platform last night I'm an
innocent man they come after me because
now we're leading in the polls Again by
a lot against Biden the indictment comes
As Trump has mounted another
presidential run his top 2024 GOP rival
Florida Governor Ron DeSantis came to
his defense on Twitter posting the
weaponization of federal law enforcement
represents a mortal threat to a free
Society President Biden defended the
Justice Department's Independence
yesterday before the end indictment news
broke I have never once
a single time
Department what they should do or not do
well to bring in a charge and operate a
charge Trump's attorneys say he's at his
golf club in Bedminster New Jersey a law
enforcement official says U.S Secret
Service will meet with Trump's staff and
Security today to arrange a plan for his
travel and arraignment which is expected
Tuesday in Miami Federal Court